OK.
It disgusts me that at this stage of the game
I have to do this story today, but I have
to do this story today.
It appears that multiple states are pick your
poison.
Having issues, lying, falsifying, distorting
corona virus testing case and or death numbers.
And there is no doubt that this is affecting
our understanding of how effectively we are
dealing with corona virus in the United States
in a bunch of different parts.
And the reason why this is just sickening
is.
Last week I came to you and I said, listen,
guys, I don't know why, but there are some
closed states, states that have been shut
down for months that are doing really no better
than some states that have opened.
Wouldn't it be amazing if states really could
reopen without seeing spikes?
Maybe that's possible.
Except now, with all of these allegations
of bogus numbers and dishonest numbers and
suppression of numbers, it becomes a lot more
difficult to know what's really going on.
So here's the deal and some of these individual
components we've already talked about in the
past.
One example was Georgia.
Georgia had reopened really early, started
on, I believe it was April 24th.
Their numbers didn't really look too bad.
They used that data to justify continuing
to reopen.
Other states said, look at what's going on
in Georgia.
We can justify reopening.
Georgia officials now admit that they had
processing errors, processing errors, which
made it look like infections were declining
when they actually were not.
That data that three times had so-called errors
was what they used to justify reopening more
and more and more when in reality the numbers
were far worse than they were publicizing.
That's Georgia, Florida, Florida.
I already told you about the situation where
cause of death was being suppressed for a
while, which was artificially holding down
corona virus deaths.
I told you last week about this data modelers
sort of tech person who was pushed out, slash,
fired.
We still don't have the full explanation after
she said, I'm not going to falsify data, which
was what she was allegedly told to do.
That's Florida, Arizona.
Arizona has become one of the most open states
and they have also become one of the fastest
spikings states on a percentage basis.
They cut off a team of health service experts
who were modeling the state data.
It wasn't looking great.
Instead, Arizona decided the governor, Republican
governor said, hey, you know what?
Let's use the federal government modeling
data, which, of course, is much more optimistic
and much more easily usable to justify reopening,
although it is not reflective of what is actually
going on in Arizona.
Then we have this other story where the CDC
and 11 different states have been sometimes
combining when they report tests, they're
combining infection and antibody tests, which
dramatically increases the testing rate on
paper, reduces the positive rate.
On paper, it doesn't actually reflect how
many people are catching the virus and how
many active infections there are.
It's absolutely insane that this has been
done.
And this includes Colorado, Delaware, Georgia,
Maine, Mississippi, Missouri, New Hampshire,
Pennsylvania, Texas, Vermont and Virginia,
all mixing infection and antibody tests at
one.
Point in their reporting, some of the states
have since fixed this, that includes places
like Vermont and Virginia.
Unclear which other states have fixed this
in which other states continue to do this.
When we have a situation like in Pennsylvania,
we are also dramatically undercounting what
the severity of the widespread infection is,
because Pennsylvania is not providing full
data on cases and deaths from nursing homes.
Nursing homes nationally have been huge hotspots
of infection in Massachusetts.
At one point, 50 or 60 percent of the deaths
were in nursing homes.
Imagine if Massachusetts said, yeah, we'll
report data except from nursing homes.
You'd think the outbreak was only half as
bad.
Nebraska at one point told meatpacking plants,
you don't have to report your cases.
And the governor wrote it off and said, well,
that's a business decision.
Now it's a public health decision and it's
one that is propagandizing the premature opening
of states.
So we've sunk lower than low.
We are doing in bits and pieces what Trump
slams China for doing, not telling the truth
about cases and deaths.
And it's happening right here.
All Americans should be outraged, period.
This borders China aside.
This borders on the totalitarian type rewriting
of reality type nonsense that we claim to
be opposed to.
We now simply cannot really believe that we
are doing better or that some states are doing
better because we're not getting accurate
information.
It is being suppressed to justify reopening
in many states.
How dare we say how dare China cover up the
numbers when we're doing the exact same thing
and they do not care?
We continue to see protests without masks.
We continue to see a lack of social distancing.
We continue to see full bars and restaurants,
often immediately within 30 minutes of states
lifting some elements of the stay at home
orders.
This is a time where, you know, listen, Massachusetts
has not been perfect.
There is no doubt Charlie Baker was not the
fastest, but he was much faster than a lot
of other states.
This is a place where, you know, when I look
at the data here in Massachusetts, number
one, I can reasonably trust the data.
There is transparency about nursing home deaths.
There is transparency about testing numbers.
The curve looks good.
We have now been under 100 deaths for a whole
bunch of days.
You know, 95 percent of a whole bunch of days.
The curve is reversing.
Testing is being ramped up.
This is one of those times where I am genuinely
glad to live in a state that is at least somewhat
tethered to truth and reality.
It's not been perfect.
It's certainly not been perfect.
But what is happening in some of these states
is borderline criminal in the sense that it
is distorting.
It is public information governed state government
releasing information that is wrong to justify
policies and actions that lead to more people
in the hospital, more people in ICU use and
more people dying.
And, you know, all of these dishonest players
trump at the top, but people at the state
level, people at local levels, they all must
suffer the consequences for their participation
in this.
We're going to keep covering this on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
I did something funny.
I posted a picture of me pre quarantine.
And now to my Instagram David Pakman.
I barely recognize pre quarantine.
It's shocking how much my physical appearance
has changed during the quarantine.
Check it out.
David got packed and we'll take a quick break.
And we have so much more coming
up
for you.